yeah very good
all right let's go get some shark teeth
okay you guys
there was a long trip wasn't it we're
here guys we made it you guys ready to
do some
all right so here we are with Moreland
State Park fossil hunting now a lot of
people jobs they walk right along the
edge and look for fossil to get washed
up or you get here really early in the
morning is the first one on the beach
but if you go just a few feet offshore
there's a Ledge where all the fossils
are hanging out we're going to go there
to scoop them up and spit them out
you're going to get to the spot nobody
else
right where the waves are breaking
there's tons of gravel that's where you
want to be yeah hold on hold on
so please do is you sort through it and
look look see there's a shark tooth
right there he's still sharp then nice
one okay so here's the thing right you
want to find patches of gravel and you
want to like mine the ground if you pull
up little gravel if I do pull up think
you're tough your travels gonna pull up
bigger teeth so you want to find the
patches with the bigger gravel unless
you just want to find a whole bunch of
little ones in you know whatever
all right so this right here you see
that that's a chunk of fossilized bone
probably from a whale see how it looks
like wood it's that kind of like the
lines in it like ordnance but it's black
thin colors Calvin's tooth yeah that
makes that's a net and that right there
is a fossilized stingray - well she's
know what that that's not a senior tooth
that's the a bit of a vertebrae you can
see that the inside of the bone hey
where's your tooth buddy what happened
to you - time to crack
oh look I found one you see it
now they hold on
okay you ready got it right here
I'll get this yeah at the tiger shark
team I think don't well once you grow
pulling out you'll get them in yeah it's
probably a joke they still sting you
maybe you don't see tons of them this
time of year
there's piece of bone
there you go
oh here we go a long perfect one is
broken off all right there we go there's
a shark tooth right there nice it tell
me take the tops right over here man
this is the secret to hey Nathan
hey maybe want to go help you no problem
I got it oh it's pretty one
they look are here crying he's right
there
oh he just went in here yeah he's wiping
their good now call VEC and I ain't put
my toes been there to get him if you are
looking for bottles and I like it this
pink will walk off with it though it is
seriously
here we go very swollen
[Music]
I'm walking the trash yeah you got it
good I'm right there hey hold on hold on
hold on no picking out my basket video
all right so you folks at home let's see
if you guys can see the shark tooth okay
see if you can find it right right there
that was in good condition you can tell
when they're in good condition because
they'll still have the serrations on the
edge they'll still have the teeth on the
edge of the piece well it's been a fun
day it's cold but not too cold
the boys are wet and Sandy and they're
going to scream like banshees when we
take them home watch this sobbing poor
delegated it's time to go home time to
go home
no dad wait
[Music]
go and hold it like this
well my header goes dark
now I need a quiz back oh so you'll get
run it I'll taste you do you want me to
go fast okay Oh tough gravel
[Applause]
thanks for watching and hopefully you
like this video if you want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel check out these great
videos and click Subscribe we put out
new videos every week thanks for
watching